so far the domestic total gross of this
film is about $5,000
I forget the filmmakers can buy a nice
used car wrecked with Adrien Brody I
guess with the film opening just like
that with him being in terrible car
accident explains why his nose looks
that way so Rex stars Adrien Brody and
Adrien Brody the film opens boom he
wakes up he's in a car wreck in the
middle of a forest the very bottom of a
ravine the car has rolled down this hill
and he's stuck inside this car the first
30 or so min to this film was very
similar to buried he can't seem to
remember his name why he was there he
has no actual memory of what happened so
he's basically stranded in the woods his
leg is all messed up and there's a big
hungry mountain lion in the woods the
best thing about this movie oh my word
it's a turn Brody for sure he is a very
good actor last thing I saw him in was
predators and he was good men films this
film requires an actor who knows how to
carry a movie without hardly seeing
anything at all on the IMDB trivia page
it says he did pretty much all of his
own stunts a lot himself to be swept
down an icy freezing cold river
he ate worms he ate bugs and he actually
stayed an entire night in the car alone
in the freezing like snowy weather all
the other cast and crew were in their
trailers and he actually stayed out
there in the cars to see what it felt
like so he's a very dedicated actor and
it really shows on screen he did a very
nice job in this movie so more positives
with the film is just the location very
believable very real I don't think any
set work whatsoever was done here I
think pretty much this whole film was
not in location see it's a high FC
midnight film and I saw it at a
screening held at an art house theater
they're just gonna be for that one day
it's in a few screenings around the
entire nation and only being shown
@midnight that's the IFC midnight thing
sure the filmmakers knew most of their
profit was gonna be coming from the fact
that it's on iTunes or on DVD and you
know the director did a pretty good job
of the fact that he had such a limited
subject now my biggest problem with this
film is this if you've seen 127 hours
then you saw film about a man who is
stuck in a terrible situation you really
wanted him to get out you just felt a
lot of hope you found a lot of joy there
was just it made you feel really good
about life you know you really he didn't
do it man he yeah that situation just
made you feel really good about that
this film has that where you think I
really wanted to make it out of the
situation but there is no joy from it
you don't feel that life-affirming
happiness joy of the human spirit you
know the situation is then you feel bad
for them just like 127 hours except you
don't feel the happiness and the joy of
the fact that he's trying as hard as he
can to get out of the situation it's
just really very dire and and you know
kind of depressing and murky in this
film also the ending of the film very
abrupt just how fast a certain event
happens and how they don't really focus
that much on it which seems weird I
don't want to give anything away
there are definitely flaws here but if
your ability is very good in this film
this film reminded me of Adrian Brody's
acting talent it's well made however
there are just certain elements to it
that are just missing the whole joy of
feeling like yes man you can do it you
can gather situation it's not there but
I'm still going to give it three out of
four stars throughout the whole movie I
was entertained by it it's just that a
fun maybe DVD watch you're not anything
to do check out wrecked
you